(religious inspired music)
- [Narrator] The Tigray
Region in Northern Ethiopia
is known for its assembly
of rock-hewn churches.
Sculpted out of sandstone,
the most wondrous of
these is Abuna Yemata Guh.
There's only one way up.
You have to climb this cliff face.
Welcome to the world's
most perilous church.
Established in the fifth century,
the church is named after its founder
and builder, Father Yemata.
Perched 650 feet above a steep cliff,
some say he chose its location
to be closer to heavenly spirits,
others argue it was a strategic
move to avoid his enemies.
Either way, the church's location,
ceiling frescoes and
precious goat skin bible
have attracted worshipers for centuries.
The church has 20 clergymen.
And is managed by this
high-ranking priest.
He has lived here for over 47 years.
And he makes the climb everyday.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] For fearless worshipers,
the two hour trek to
the top begins by hiking
to the bottom of the rock
from the valley below.
Visitors must first remove
their shoes before climbing.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] The final obstacle
to the church's entrance
can test the most ardent pilgrim's faith.
A narrow cliff ledge with
a deadly drop to left
and no room for error.
Once through you may
think you're in heaven,
but you've never felt more alive.
(speaking foreign language)